what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so a couple of things first off some of
you have said that you were unsubscribe
to my channel not really sure why I
assume it goes into the whole YouTube
algorithm thing is currently going on I
don't really need to talk about that
most everybody knows about that but some
of you have also said that you're like
not getting notifications when my videos
go up and I've actually done a couple
Twitter polls odd to see you know
whether or not people are struggling
with that if you're one of those folks
and if you just want to if you look down
where the subscribe button is you'll
actually see a little bell and if you
click on that little bell it'll pop up
with an option for you to receive
notifications by like push whatever that
means or email I think pushes like on
mobile but it'll know you've notify you
as soon as one of my videos goes up so
you guys can always stay on top of
things
having said that during this time to
play the game oh my god when it comes to
you I miss right I miss old school
wrestling so much I'm so bad when it
comes to tangents on my youtube channel
I go on rants ah it is it's it's very
bad for me being able to do any one
thing at any one particular point in
time
hashtag ad D so we have a vs. series for
all the people who are new here to my
channel of course we take two characters
who have never met and we face them off
against one another sometimes well
sometimes they've met but usually they
haven't know so it's like Ghost Rider
versus spawn or it's some variation of
that Marvel vs. DC mobile versus valiant
model versus image something along those
lines anyway in this video we're gonna
be covering Goku blue and Superman 1
million sometimes call Superman Prime
now the reason why I say Goku blue is
because I'm not gonna say Super Saiyan
God Super Saiyan Goku throughout the
course of this video that's obnoxious
instead we're just gonna say Goku blue
because it makes a whole lot more sense
another thing also wanna let you guys
know is that this video was made with
the help of geekdom 101 so you guys
should walk on over to his youtube
channel which you'll find down in the
description and say what's up man and
subscribe because his channel is growing
by leaps and bounds it's insane how well
his channels is doing right now but you
guys should definitely check him out
because that Danny's a pretty solid guy
when it comes to Dragon Ball related
content so as always when it comes to
these vs. videos please keep an open
mind
I know as
a lot to do when it comes to Goku vs
Superman because it's it's such a
debated topic that people are like like
my favorite hero needs to win if my
favorite character doesn't win well then
this video doesn't know what they're
talking about that's just the way it is
you know if there's an inconceivable
that my favorite guy couldn't win like
like we get like that as as fans of
comics fans of anime manga you know that
kind of thing we latch on to our
favorite characters and we hate to see
them loose but please be reasonable in
the comments section that being said as
always we kick things off running over
who the characters are so starting with
Goku blue this version of Goku is
alternatively referred to as Super
Saiyan God Super Saiyan Goku and what
that basically means is that this
version of Goku has gone super saiyan
while possessing the Super Saiyan God
power now to make sense out of this the
Super Saiyan God form is an extremely
powerful form that Goku first achieved
in Dragon Ball Z battle of the gods in
order to fight the god of destruction
beerus the original Super Saiyan God was
created by a group of ancient righteous
Saiyans that pooled their power together
through a mysterious ritual took him bad
evil sands on the planet Vegeta however
due to the time constraints of the form
they ultimately failed now the dragon
Shenron reveals this to Goku and his
friends and states that it is Scripture
taken from the namekian book of legends
and so to combat beerus goku pulled his
power with vegeta trunks goat and Gohan
and Videl
unborn child and in doing so achieved
the Super Saiyan God level now while
this is impressive in and of itself
Goku later achieves the next
transformations through training from
beerus 'as mentor weeks which allows him
to assume Super Saiyan God Super Saiyan
form which exactly as the name suggests
is the Super Saiyan form of a Super
Saiyan God when in this form Goku can
tap into his own godly ki and combine
that with his internal key which allows
him to effectively exercise full control
over his ability now in terms of how
powerful Super Saiyan blue Goku is we
know that in this Super Saiyan God form
that the punches thrown during Dokus
battle with beerus produced aftershocks
that could be felt throughout the
universe with that in mind we know that
Goku's punches in Super Saiyan blue form
are even more powerful than that
although just how powerful they are has
not yet been established due to how
recent of a development the Super Saiyan
blue form is in subsequent battles with
golden Frieza
Goku black Super Saiyan blue Goku's
ability to constrict the flow of energy
in his body has prevented the same
aftershocks from occurring and possibly
damaging the earth and nearby planets
Goku has also proven that he is able to
use the kaio-ken technique which can
make his attacks ten times more powerful
than usual when this technique is used
while Goku is in Super Saiyan blue form
it allows Goku to use extraordinarily
powerful attacks this technique however
is not without its drawbacks each time
Goku uses this technique he puts his
life on the line as it depletes his
energy reserves to such an extent that
it takes him days to recover from using
it another limitation of Goku's power
has recently been revealed in the Dragon
Ball super manga and that Goku is
weakened each time he transforms into
Super Saiyan blue beyond the initial
powerup meaning that the upper limits of
his power in this form is lessened with
each subsequent transformation and so
now that we've covered Goku we're going
to turn our attention to Superman prime
or Superman 1 million so Superman prime
is a creation of Grant Morrison that
made his debut during the 1998 series DC
1 million for that reason he sometimes
referred to as Superman 1 million or
simply Superman prime 1 million but
Superman prime is basically the Superman
of the post-crisis on Infinite Earths
continuity as he existed in the 850 3rd
century during this timeline after
everyone that he had cared about had
basically died a Superman left earth at
the end of the 21st century and traveled
across the universe until around the
700th century gaining a multitude of
skills and abilities along the way after
that he retires to his Fortress of
Solitude
in the center of the Sun where he would
spend 15,000 years
soaking up the power of the Yellow Sun
which is the source of his power now if
you want a more detailed explanation of
Superman Prime I've actually done a
video on him which will goes in a more
detail about his character and that you
could find down in the description but
as far as what Superman's primes powers
are well that part gets a little tricky
as I explained in my previous video
Superman Prime has only made a handful
of appearances in comics so it's
difficult to really know what the extent
of his powers are and to be honest most
of the commonly cited feats of Superman
prime have either been misinterpreted or
Mis attributed to him which we go into
in my previous video but with that being
said even though we don't have a lot of
information we can make some pretty
solid inferences based on what we know
about Superman's powers what we know is
that due to his Kryptonian
Superman's cells are able to store
energy from yellow Suns so that he can
access his powers in the absence of a
Yellow Sun until those reserves are
depleted in the case of Superman Prime
he's been absorbing Yellow Sun energy
for fifteen thousand years what this
means is that not only are his powers of
astronomically high levels but he's
presumably stored up an almost
inexhaustible cache of energy which he
can draw on
now due to the limited number of
appearances that he's made we don't
really have a lot of feats to look at
engage how powerful Superman prime is
however we can look at some of the
things Superman has done in his regular
form which is impressive enough in and
of itself and surmised that he'd be able
to do much greater things than these
as Superman Prime in his regular form
Superman's made comments that he's been
able to destroy planets with the force
of his punch and that he's proven the
ability to destroy asteroids and meteors
he's even broken through the barriers of
space and time and punched death in the
face now as far as Superman's durability
we've seen him stand up to
disintegration beams fire from
apocalypse and a cosmic radiation storm
keep in mind we're only talking about
the normal post crisis iterations of
Superman here not Superman prime
Superman prime would be able to do all
these things and many many more so it's
not an exaggeration to conclude the
Superman prime is for all intents and
purposes indestructible and furthermore
that there is likely no upper limit to
his strength and so now that we've gone
over both of these characters let's get
into the nitty-gritty who the most
dangerous part of this video and decide
who would win well obviously these are
two insanely powerful characters which
is why the matchup is so interesting to
so many people and so often requested by
viewers in addition to their immense
power each of these characters has a
strong fan following that's both massive
and fiercely devoted that being said
whichever character I declare the winner
a good portion of you are going to be
upset knowing that I still have to say I
think that Superman prime wins this
battle fairly easily the reason why is
that I just don't think we've seen
anything from Goku even in a Super
Saiyan blue form that even comes close
to the power that we can reasonably
assume Superman prime possesses while
Goku is extremely strong and durable we
know that he does have limitations
especially as it relates to seminole on
the other hand Superman Prime has a
seemingly limitless source of yellow sun
energy to amp up his powers to
exponential levels and keep him powered
up
for as long as it takes for Goku to
exhaust himself this gigantic stored
energy is also what would allow Superman
primed to emerge victorious
even if Goku were to use Instant
Transmission to separate Superman from a
Yellow Sun either by teleporting him to
a dimension without one or even
destroying the Sun itself as Superman
would still have enough energy to draw
on and keep him going for an extended
yet indefinite amount of time but with
that being said I know there's gonna be
some more so many angry people how could
you say the Superman 1 million would
beat Goku Bloo that's that's outrageous
but if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you guys drop a like and I know a
lot of you guys are very very sure about
who it is that would well no you guys
are staunchly protective of your
favorite heroes so what I've done is I
basically jumped on Twitter you guys can
finally on there at comets explained and
I've set up a Twitter poll that will run
for 24 hours and the idea I'm gonna give
you two options
Goku blue or Superman 1 million your
goal or if you want to is to select
which one you think would win and that
will tell me without any shadow of a
doubt who would actually come up on top
and your eyes but with that being said
we're gonna bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you guys are
new here - how much explain make sure
you hit the subscribe button to become
part of the Rob core and yeah I will
catch you all later peace
[Applause]
[Music]